so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas dobiziola
whatever you want to call me this is my
co-host Marty O'Neal what's up folks
what up this is the dope as usual
podcast we're gonna talk about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between today we have a a
ask for a fan favorite right here ddg
thank you so much for being here man
what's up man appreciate you having me
man
appreciate it man so yes sir so we've
been talking a little bit since you
since they got here a little early
I I wasn't on the I'm I'm a YouTuber
that doesn't watch YouTube does that
makes do you are you on the same path
yeah I'm kind of the same way right you
got like two maybe two other people you
really like yeah I've seen it yeah yeah
all right
so from the path of going from YouTube
to music because I'm kind of like on my
back end I do weed content and [ __ ] so
I've been doing it for like nine years
like we have like a really big Channel
on YouTube for wheat so for you to
transition from the YouTuber to making
music
do you kind of have that like
I hope people don't find this kind of
like what are you doing do you have that
yeah I got a lot of that you do okay I
kind of had to like you're trying to be
podcaster bro yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
talking yeah yeah no I got I definitely
got some
cringy stuff online you know but you
know pays the bills man
so you know it is what it is once you
start doing YouTube I started seven
years ago
oh that's it seven yeah almost seven
eight I started yeah about seven eight
years something like that I believe what
were you doing would you have a
direction when you started I was just
doing skits oh yeah yeah same [ __ ] yeah
I was doing like because that's what
that was popping back then fine man
you're probably just off the vine yeah
yeah I was starting on yeah I started on
Vine and then I got banned from Vine
because I don't know why I did it but I
posted like it was like a girl she was
like it was funny but she was like naked
in the vine but I wasn't thinking you
know what I mean I'm just thinking like
I'm just funny yeah it's funny they end
up closing my account so then I had like
15 000 followers or something and I was
like you know what let me try YouTube
no I'm here man same shot same [ __ ] wow
I got shut down I'm on my 27th Instagram
like they shut me down non-stop right
yeah and then I like fifth count 15 I'm
like I'm going to YouTube I'm gonna try
YouTube yeah exactly the same [ __ ] that
happened to me but uh I remember the day
they bought Vine and shut it down man
yeah Vine I don't know why they did that
bro I [ __ ] them more than Tick Tock
you said hey like who bought it someone
just bought my homie Nick you remember
Nick colletti on Vine the white the
funny ass white dude probably I got to
see him ah that [ __ ] was trying
to buy pieces of Vine when it was
shutting down I remember and it was just
I know you don't watch mine it's like
Tick Tock but it was just
oh you've never seen Vine I mean I've
seen it I wasn't like on it and [ __ ] I
wasn't fine it was the [ __ ] hell yeah it
was Tick-Tock but six seconds that's it
yeah six seconds
it was crazy but the people was doing
like the funniest [ __ ] in six seconds I
couldn't imagine we were just we were
watching like your sketches in your
videos like basically all morning and
[ __ ] yeah bro well done like it's like
the actor and just how they're shot and
how they look but they're like Vlogs I
was waiting for the character break
that's me and him all right character
the whole time I was like all right are
you editing these two yeah edit
sometimes but um I kind of GRE out of
that and just hired somebody I'm like
but early on it was just you and the
camera not even early on about two
months ago a month ago I was oh good
[ __ ] what did you use Final Cut Pro oh
see you I was using I use rush until
like recent Premiere Rush not even Adobe
Premiere Pro like I use rush because I'm
illiterate with computers bro he's my
editor like like all my Wii videos and
[ __ ] he does before I'm just chop like
iMovie days like that's all I could do
man I'm a low-key like a I'm a I'm a
real editor but like oh crap all right
in my Vlogs like five ten minutes I'm
just yeah because I know what I recorded
type [ __ ] yeah you almost edit yourself
talking about edit kind of like why I'm
recording exactly type [ __ ] because you
know when to take the I'll take it again
my breath up hold on yeah oh so yeah
you're a real vlogger then yeah yeah uh
this is I like this episode already then
we were watching the video that you did
with your nephew for the album released
because I mean obviously one of the big
things we're here to talk about is this
album release but I thought it was so
creative how you did it like a little
like
that's good series in like five minutes
yeah he's a real prodo yeah
I just I literally just told him I was
like all right trying to do his little
skit with me for my arm real quick and
he was like yeah so then we went in the
room and then I was like um all right I
need you to basically just listen to act
like you listen to it real quick and
then tell me why is it only 12 songs
because everybody was saying like you
only gave us 12 songs and two of them
interludes and three of them was already
out blah blah blah so I had him just
reiterate that to like kind of relate to
the people and then he did everything
else oh he just ain't probed all that
yeah I just told him how to I just told
him how to spell out all the the song
titles little kid writing like mine yeah
yeah yeah yeah
what was it was his dad run off
downstairs at the end that was yeah it's
good that's that's me and him
Storyteller storytelling little [ __ ]
it's like promoting without like shoving
I'm just promoting my albums on your
throat yeah cause I feel like I gotta I
gotta do it in a in a in a fun way
because it's a lot of people that still
I gotta transition over to my music from
my YouTube you know what I'm saying so I
feel like when I do it in a YouTube
format and make it fun and make people
like let me go check out this [ __ ]
exactly Miller Lite commercials the
man's cake commercial like I come from
making skits and [ __ ] just stupid weed
stuff when Instagram uh remember the
explore page yeah that's when I was like
posting packs and like that's what I
come from making stupid skits and [ __ ]
so seeing them like oh he puts effort
into it even though he's making music I
[ __ ] with it yeah
welcome to fresh ball fall it's the
season of pumpkin spice and making sure
your pubes look nice it's manscaped with
the Platinum package 4.0 you can align
all of your hygienic routine stuff in
one box the skin safe technology is on
the weed whacker it's on the lawnmower
features of the ear hair trimmer the
nose hair trimmer every single thing to
keep yourself 100 hygienic prepped ready
to go we got the crop preserver ball
toner we got the crop reviver ball
deodorant making sure your balls are
smelling as festive as your pits this
season remember manscape now offers
deodorant aluminum free deodorant and in
the Platinum package 4.0 manscape has
thrown in two free gifts that's the
boxers and the travel bag a travel bag I
have in my house I use it for all my
bathroom stuff when I travel obviously
go to manscape.com use code Yola get 20
off and free shipping support the
podcast plus get 20 off your order free
shipping manscape.com code YOLO that's
code Yola at manscape.com forward slash
Yola 20 off plus free shipping and
remember it's fresh ball fall
how much weed is in his butt uh that's
an eighth
oh 3.1 probably this is the biggest
blender I've ever seen oh yeah joint
joint oh we're gonna hang out we should
hang out more I never seen this big what
the [ __ ] yeah that's the regular
conversation it's called The Story Time
drawing oh story time that's great he'll
tell a little story where you're
chilling okay cool you got a lighter
over there ready I got one yeah
yeah
cool all right so basically
um you just gotta have a tour why not
last year wait last year I did a
European tour the European tour is what
I'm talking about yeah so from doing
YouTube just doing your thing because
when you're doing YouTube I don't get
relate perfect you're not expecting like
yo in two months I'm gonna be blowing up
and then I'm gonna get paid and I'm
gonna get a car you don't think that way
right so from that to do a European tour
what is that man what's that feeling of
getting on stage and I mean that's
that's my favorite part of the music
[ __ ] is performing like it's
it's different when you went because me
coming from like YouTube and [ __ ]
you like you see the numbers that's
really it you know what I'm saying but I
feel like I love music so much because
you can actually see it in real life
when you go out there and I perform Moon
walking in Calabasas and I literally
hear everybody singing this [ __ ] and I'm
the DJ Cut the music off I do the mic
like this and they rapping it like
that's like the best feeling for me and
there's almost a fear of like pleasing
all these words
I feel you dude it's a it's YouTube live
chat in person yeah basically all the
positive [ __ ] you guys really I feel you
yeah when I get on stage I I like turn
into a different person like it's like
I've become like a
you know what I'm saying I don't know
how to explain it but it's like I I feel
like the crowd juicy yeah juice I'm like
Juiced on stage adrenaline things yeah
I'll be jumping off the stage yeah it's
game day yeah yeah were you balling out
of control successful YouTuber before
music or what were you already really
successful they pay you right YouTube
pays you when you started doing your
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah I don't get paid
that's why I was I have to ask oh you
don't get paid on the ass cause the weed
huh yeah yeah yeah so you were getting
paid because I read he dropped correct
me if I'm wrong but you dropped out of
college because your YouTube was like
yeah getting so big but yeah uh I
dropped out 2016. you know I mean like
what year of college were you in like
first year oh so you were I was I was
first it was first semester sophomore
oh so you know what the [ __ ] you were
doing that summer was your contemplating
like yeah I don't think or was it once
in summers when I really took off after
my freshman year this summer I started
making dummy money and I'm like [ __ ] I
get back to school and then I'm like
what the [ __ ] I'm waking up at hey wait
for someone to say something dumb just
so you could justify I'm out I know what
you I know yeah that's how I quit
college yeah one more person say
something stupid I'm gonna I sell
because I was selling packs Mike I can
this Fool's bugging me I need to pay my
rent College isn't that important to me
that's how I felt why I quit I was like
what's the point yeah no I feel you and
I was doing Instagram and YouTube stuff
when I was in college so it's almost
like I don't want to be here Fool's
gonna be like asking me questions and
[ __ ] I feel kind of awkward and then
eventually get through it and oh yeah I
do YouTube [ __ ] yeah right yeah yeah I
never talked to somebody else that you
know has the same YouTube [ __ ] yeah it's
cool success yeah YouTube is a beautiful
platform man yeah I [ __ ] with the dude
um the European tour what's your
favorite part of that
my favorite part I would say was uh I
had it was like rolling loud Portugal
damn and they had it in Portugal it was
like on the beach wow that was lit so I
was um it was only two that was like one
of my first times performing on like the
big big stage or whatever
so I had hella people at my set and
that's the best that's the best feeling
you know what I'm saying and they only
had two stages so it's like you either
here or there so it's like yeah usually
you're rolling a lot like Miami they got
like five different states you got
everybody split up every [ __ ] word
you know what I'm saying you might [ __ ]
around get a bad time or you might get a
time as a huge artist at the same time
and everybody over there you know what
I'm saying and it's like damn
yeah you gotta think about all that [ __ ]
so I had the perfect lineup nobody I
wasn't competing with nobody that was
like bigger than me or no [ __ ] and it
was just like
I had everybody at my [ __ ] so it was fun
[ __ ] was crazy that's sick Bro yeah he
was lit I jumped off the stage yeah I'd
be my spitting man that's like a [ __ ]
that's a different feeling man what's
the difference for you and [ __ ] because
I just did my first meet and greet like
real one outside of California in uh
Indiana we picked Hobart Indiana little
ass place outside of Chicago
I never felt that [ __ ] in my life so
that's what I'm trying to relate like
how does that feel because I always have
the fear of like people care but do they
really give a [ __ ] like that'd be cool
for people like yo what's up I walk down
people are screaming like I was making
music and [ __ ] a thousand [ __ ]
waiting in lie I couldn't believe it
yeah no so that feeling you're getting
that's a different country don't speak
the language and [ __ ] yeah so yeah he's
been Portugal that's a whole different
thing like if I make videos are you
worried like going there at all like
these super fireplaces like damn I hope
black people are gonna really be showing
up and I mean at the time I mean it's a
festival so it's like the you ain't got
to sell no tickets the people there for
sure you know what I'm saying it's just
about [ __ ] that's there knowing
your music and you want to turn up but
most and you're in Europe like it was
some places I went to like Netherlands
and [ __ ] like that and I went to like
I want every [ __ ] word I can't even
tell you like it was like
I went everywhere Amsterdam when I was
doing the Europe [ __ ] like even if they
don't speak English and they don't
really know your [ __ ] like that they
still turn they more turnt in the US
they I feel like the United States we
too cool too cool without it it's we're
oversaturated yeah we got everything we
got every artist you want here you know
what I'm saying there's so many people
to choose from so it's like you like
what you like if I don't really [ __ ]
with you I ain't jumping up and down but
you see that in UFC like how the other
countries get behind like McGregor look
at soccer we don't really do that yeah
and they chanting and [ __ ] all types of
[ __ ] so overseas they they [ __ ] with
Americans like crazy
so you know I ain't even it was fun it
was all fun for me did you forget any
like YouTuber fans like bro I've been
following you for years outside of this
Mission every day every day every day
yeah
I grew up watching you since College
yeah
um sixth grade I'm in college now I'll
be like damn yeah that's what I'm saying
I turned 25 in four days oh man you're
young [ __ ] bro so you really just did
music because you just really looked
like I really want to do this like I can
why not
the real reason why I started like I was
already doing music like I always [ __ ]
with music I always like I used to do
songs when I was like six years old
seven years old oh [ __ ] my dad was like
a engineer in my hometown Pontiac and um
we had like our own little home studio
so I used to go down there my brothers
[ __ ] around yeah I always loved music
but I started the YouTube [ __ ] and it
kind of like took off and you know I'm
saying all this [ __ ] start happening and
then uh YouTube had like a ad apocalypse
I don't know if you know about that
adpocalypse it was basically that's what
they call it but basically advertisers
pulled out of YouTube right oh no I
didn't know that I was making like 50 50
a month on there I went down to college
no no I just got out of college then it
went to then it went to 8 000.
I'm like wait a second because by the
time I rent 5K I'm standing um Hollywood
1600 Vine right oh we're all the
YouTubers yeah yeah I was in the cut you
know what I'm saying I was with
everybody else so that [ __ ] five
thousand a month I'm like God damn this
[ __ ] ain't right so then I start let me
let me focus on this rap [ __ ] because I
was blowing up off diss tracks and [ __ ]
and then that's how you started and
that's how I started taking music like
really really serious
and I just started you know I just
started that transition phase
damn right so for real that's unique
path yeah well then again when kind of
when your back's on the wall you have to
think like what am I best at what do I
want to do I'm an adapter you see the
it's either acting or music for me
acting have you ever have you ever acted
before I mean I kind of I kind of act in
my videos besides like but I never like
really
tried to really go in on the career as
an actor I did like one independent
movie like 2000 red lines and [ __ ] yeah
but it was like a small little
um roll and [ __ ] it wasn't nothing crazy
even if the like
I bet like because I just did like my
first kind of dialogue [ __ ] you know you
got those lines and then as soon as you
step up like I'm about to embarrass the
[ __ ] on myself yeah yeah and it ain't
live though so you good you know I just
had hella cruises I'm like dude these
fools and I'm the weed guy yeah so
they're like y'all was supposed to
smoking joints the whole time
comes up and forgets his line like I
don't want to be like that [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying
um what was the movie about what did you
do
I was a drive-through um person oh I
took an order at a drive-through this is
why you're doing YouTube huh so how did
you get into that someone just asked you
from your channel somebody that I knew
needed knew somebody that needed
somebody for a movie so I was like so
let me go ahead and try this [ __ ] I I
hated it though
I was on set for like that's really why
I really
kind of like I'm cool off this [ __ ]
except for 12 hours to act 12 hours to
act for [ __ ] 10 minutes my part was
three minutes I was there for 14 hours
I'm like bruh yeah doing me dirt and I'm
and I'm and no cocky [ __ ] I was the
Littest [ __ ] there I'm like if y'all at
least give me some type of priority you
know what I'm saying let me film first
or something yeah that's what I'm saying
like bro I've been sitting here for five
hours bro what's up then it turned into
10 and it turned into 12 and I did my
little part and I never want to do it
again never wanted to do it again yeah
my video was three minutes it was a 15
hour shoot yeah like get this [ __ ] out
of here I mean I had fun just because
scene I do film [ __ ] so like watching
[ __ ] film was cool to me but
yeah it wasn't cool sitting there
checking my phone every time you're not
having the cameras and [ __ ] it's wow
you gotta have real patience for this
[ __ ] yeah you better get paid I feel
like when I get to that you know that
point I feel like now I get a big roll
if I really yeah took acting on and now
I'd be actually working and not sitting
around type [ __ ]
no that's cool man and then you just had
your uh album fully dropped like what a
month a month ago right
no I don't even knows what the 22nd no
that was a week ago a week ago wait I
thought it was September oh my God it's
October yeah
we kicked in
[ __ ] well my I've been [ __ ] up since
Rosie's been out my fiance had surgery
and [ __ ] so I'm like what do you need
all right I'ma smoke this joint all
right I'm gonna go film so my weeks are
like this and I've been [ __ ] uh
flying for two weeks so let's do it I
feel off I like how long you've been uh
engaged
engaged we're pulling the office thing
right now we're like a year and a half
but they've been together for like
[ __ ] 11 almost 11 years now yeah they
didn't make a change when you got [ __ ]
no it's the same when you get that's the
same once once it's uh
me and her best friends so we both look
chill like do you give a [ __ ] right now
I don't give a [ __ ] and then like a week
later I'm gonna get it ring I'm gonna go
[ __ ] fine you know I was trying to
make and I do YouTube so I was vlogging
like hey babe we're gonna do a YouTube
Vlog and all the places you sell packs
so I was taking her through a vlog but
she didn't know every time she turned
around like
she had no idea it was about like I was
about to pop it on her ass for like and
I went to my old spot where I started
selling packs our first house look we
used to chill here you just out here
trapping and getting married yeah
but I literally pulled the what is that
and she looked it worked I did it I
couldn't believe it worked like that
[ __ ] only happens in movies like hey on
the front porch or the push trees house
yep that's supposed to be me I used to
sell packs I was like yo this is [ __ ]
funny and then I started brand that's
how it happened but yeah doing YouTuber
[ __ ] I was like you know what let me
turn this into a [ __ ] Vlog because
when I'm 50 like remember when I
proposed to you no watch it I don't know
I think like you can relate to yeah my
life's on camera yeah you know people
see you grow up too because you started
at what age 17 yeah around 17 17 18 yeah
that's crazy so all right back to that
you had your album come out
oh yeah yes sir and now they're getting
what four more tracks for the deluxe
yeah what's the what's the right line
tonight it's coming out tonight it's on
Monday so it's out so basically it's out
because yeah this one comes out in like
three days so yeah yeah it's featuring
oh I saw the features man yeah featuring
offset
then I gotta join with Corey Ray and
lakia
bro for I know because you're for
getting YouTube you're doing your music
thing what year did you decide the
adpocalypse what year was that
that was like 2017 I think the end of
2017 2018. but it started coming back
though right the ads came back and money
came back yeah yeah everything's better
okay it was like somebody posted
something and put an ad on on the video
so the advertise CNN like hell no we
give us our million back no I was
getting uh Donald Trump ads and weed ads
on my [ __ ] and I was never even getting
paid
so you got a lot of big [ __ ]
features on this album I'm assuming a
lot of people you listened to before
fans of I know like
they'll say don't ever meet your Idols
type [ __ ] but it's not really meeting
your Islands meeting colleagues at that
point because you're yeah you know
you're on the same level as these people
yeah so but I still know the kid inside
is like yo shut the [ __ ] I'm about to
text my home like you know I'm in the
booth with right now you still get that
a little bit nah yeah I keep it to
myself exactly keep it to yourself but
you might text them like yeah he was
cool bro remember we were listening to
smoking blunts in our car I can't
believe I'm chilling with it not to
mention he's the first person ever out
of like Pontiac right I mean we have the
whole obvious D12 era of like Detroit
and all that [ __ ] so really I mean like
seven years back yeah just putting on
really a whole area through the genre of
music too at the same time when you're
growing up who's the biggest artist on
the radio like that you could remember
like golden school but hey okay so
you're like 2001 2004 just yeah
exactly yeah right yeah yeah okay yeah
that makes sense I had all the games and
[ __ ] all the video games
[ __ ] game was dope as hell it was
good it was actually a good ass game it
was like
ahead of its time and nobody remembers
this [ __ ] do you remember the Scarface
game yeah that [ __ ] was there's another
games out that's fire you ever play The
Warriors
of course that's the Warriors game was
sick Uncle John
it's dope games oh [ __ ] entertaining is
[ __ ] do you ever play that game man hunt
came in prison yeah I never got into it
though I got stuck on a level and I
never got past it yeah that was it I was
just I turned it into GameStop
that's what happened bro
I could [ __ ] win
I got stuck in a cell and was like find
your way out with Clues like there's no
clue
[ __ ] up a level ago and didn't pick up
a key I'm gonna start problem solving
I'm tapping I'm out I just want to play
Madden at that point in GTA and shoot
somebody yeah yeah
are we good
yeah yeah we're just doing a battery
switch on our camera switch okay are we
good on these we're good yeah all right
I'm gonna go back and do it here we go
yep all right so yeah so we're talking
about manhunting [ __ ] yeah man I got
stuck in that cell I never played the
game again
um so as a kid you're 50 cents the the
one that's big so I'm trying to get like
the era of music who is your top though
like who are your like legends that you
grew up that you consider like maybe
your top three
I mean [ __ ]
I was like one of them kids that just
get in the car and listen to what my
mama listen too well she listened to
then that's cool I listen to a lot of r
b and [ __ ] and like what like Kim and
Lyfe Jennings and [ __ ] oh damn your mom
was bumping she was bumping that [ __ ] I
ain't gonna laugh she yeah so I like
like what's in that Charlie Wilson
[Music]
Otis um ready yeah Reddit
yeah that was me too as a kid but but my
my mom took me on the wrong path Tell Me
Biggie Smalls wasn't good just because
she was like a teenager when like West
coaster East Coast you know my mom was
grew up in that so she's like no Tupac
Only so I didn't get to listen to Biggie
Smalls in my house legitimately at all
she didn't because my mom woke us up
every day it was either ODB DMX or some
oldie or the Bee Gees
spumping that's how we wake up for
school I mean it was a cool way to wake
up I'll say that but uh yeah I wasn't
allowed to listen to the east coast rap
as much as I would like except for DMX
and ODB what the [ __ ] an ODB yeah but I
mean the [ __ ] that I would listen to now
you know okay so your album came out you
dropped a couple of videos the Elon Musk
one you actually got to go to the nasty
spot
yeah man I went to space
yes sir so it says in rope you [ __ ]
the robotics in high school and I'm like
so wait
it's gonna work he's kind of like a nerd
kind of like us right so through high
school you're I'm a cool nerd that's
exactly the best way
should I tell them yeah
I ain't telling nobody this is exclusive
for y'all okay all right
I was in high school I graduated
valedictorian 4.0 oh
I got Mass two of the year I was a
little preppy kid until I started
smoking weed in eighth grade yeah I
start smoking weeds as I moved out here
like oh [ __ ] for real yeah I had my
first drink when I was
17 I think oh you really were that
validatorian because weed's been kind it
was just I just never got into it until
that time but
but if you went to parties if I have a
tour and you play sports you were not
the kid that got kicked out of party so
you were around it you just didn't
really [ __ ] with it yeah but when I got
to college I was really around it you
know what I'm saying you're an athlete
though right
it's something like that I played
baseball I ran track in high school yeah
so that's probably like something like
that when someone says that music yeah
no I mean it's like I'm a tester
Collegiate athlete yeah I will say a lot
of people say I'm like they compare me
to like Steph Curry and [ __ ] for
basketball
yeah we had about a secret athletes on
this [ __ ] show what was it Chevy
Woods like yeah I'm like a dunk a
basketball player I went to the [ __ ]
League like what
all right that's cool so you're growing
up you're valedictorian
which is off the bat wild as hell
first on the maybe Dr Drew maybe Doctor
Doctor Drew he would have mentioned that
that's true I don't I don't know anybody
else's about Victorian like I try to
meet other valedictorians but I never
meet him
so
competitive with everything it's a sport
I looked at school as like a sport 100
I'm like man
damn if I do this I could [ __ ] around
and get this grade like I looked at it
like a video game yeah that's why I
really was so good at this company the
dopest I have to video games yeah
because they used to rank us and [ __ ]
yeah they used to put it on the wall
like who got the highest grade point
yeah cafeteria yeah and I'm trying to
get to the top I'm like and then I'll be
flexing me at the top of shape it was
cool but I was still like the you know
like the Ladies Man in school you know
what I'm saying all around yeah perfect
sun
your dad must have been Juiced yeah I
was playing politics too I was getting
cooler with the teachers and [ __ ] like
doing staying after school helping them
I understand I got a few gray bumps off
that [ __ ]
I was selling candy I used to sell Andy
I was selling let me tell you my um
inventory I had
air heads three four dollar the little
ones are big little ones I'm very dark
yeah okay I used to go to um Gordon's
Food Service to get all this [ __ ] get it
in both yeah yeah then I had chips Hot
Cheetos all the hot ones charged a
dollar for each bag the small bags
then I had Capri Suns I had all this
[ __ ] in like two backpacks in my locker
and I had like some cans of lemonade and
[ __ ]
yeah I was selling good honey buns too
honey buns [ __ ] prison over here yeah
he had the whole honey buns and spreads
yeah what the [ __ ] no I used to make
like a hundred dollars a day like did
you have to hide it from the school like
yeah yeah I got caught a few times yeah
I think I pissed yeah yeah and then it
was a [ __ ] I used to compete with the
um National Honor Society they were
selling like [ __ ] for charity after
school so like they'd be hating on me
because I'll be selling candy and people
already have food and [ __ ] it was crazy
no I like the approach stepping on their
toes when I asked like yo you have this
cover of like the auditorium everyone's
cool they gotta respect it on the weed
on the side no I was legitimately
selling candy competing with the schools
yo where are you in every school what
the [ __ ] so all we had was like kids
that sold meth in my school we didn't
have nothing tight like that kids that
had kids in my school yeah I wasn't
around I wasn't around drugs like that
to even like
which I'm glad I wasn't but I wouldn't
yeah I wasn't around drugs like that to
like really sell that [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying so it was like awesome man
yeah so I was like candy this is the
legal way what the [ __ ] like making
money I had to make money it's really
funny you say that because on his clean
channel on the adventure Channel that's
our code word for drugs
okay that's crazy me too no I had a
little hole I had a whole ring with my
homie Joe at the school like we'd stash
it and pipe drain pipes and bricks and
go grab sack stuff little kid [ __ ] like
drug [ __ ] but it was fun man so you're
selling candy valedictorian your dad's
Juiced he's got the [ __ ] cool kid and
he's got a 4.0 damn that doesn't even
sound that sounds like some Will Smith
did his work I was a boxer too man
you're knocking people out yeah man no
one can [ __ ] with you once you start
turning your box around like early right
I started when I was nine how'd that
start like you just wanted to my homies
was boxing in school so I just wanted to
you know do extracurricular activity
with my homies and [ __ ] and then I end
up really [ __ ] with it and I got so
good at it like if you can go there to
this day it's called Azteca boxing gym
it's in Pontiac you go up there and
you'll see my my faces when I was like
12 years old and they say outstanding
boxer of the year like it was a it's
like that's all I wanted like the same
[ __ ] with school all I wanted was to be
on that wall it's outstanding box of the
year so I'm whooping [ __ ] ass
no spawn I was actually competing like I
won silver glove Champion oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah like Junior Olympics I did what the
[ __ ] yeah it was you were an athlete I
was really going after this [ __ ] then I
got
I'll stay in the box of the year so you
how long did that take not long I would
imagine it was like second year I bet
yeah it was like my third year and [ __ ]
like I was just fighting Yo outstanding
box of the year how old we like we said
like 12 right oh no no yeah you're about
12 at this time yeah
[Music]
no one's poking this one at school no
one's saying [ __ ] to you no one's making
fun of you for getting straight A's it's
like nothing I can dunk on you I could
cross you outrun you and beat your ass
and then your girlfriend likes me this
is some [ __ ] man that was a good kid
yeah you're a good kid are you an only
child nope how many brothers and sisters
you got two brothers two sisters are you
dead in the middle yep I don't know
me too how did I know yeah oh damn okay
so your other your older brothers were
they end up boxing and music or are you
just that where they used they was like
singers
[ __ ] yeah yeah oh cause your dad's a
producer huh yeah it was like singing
and [ __ ] my mama used to help him sing
and [ __ ] so I was just the kid you know
I was just a little brother and [ __ ]
and I end up being an artist so how
what's the age gaps six years oh damn
those are not even like your close older
brothers six years is so far apart
especially when you're six and
motherfucker's twelve yeah you can't
come to the store with him like you're
too small get the [ __ ] away from me damn
all right what do they do now
well one of my brothers passed away oh
so yeah but my other brother he do
YouTube too oh no [ __ ] yeah so he like
he like like my little nephew his dad
all the photos running down the stairs
in your little skit all right so yeah he
does YouTube yep so he'll do YouTube too
he got a million over a million
subscribers like his [ __ ] bumping nice
it's like my whole family do that [ __ ]
does your dad do YouTube too yeah what I
thought I was like I thought I saw that
hey everybody on YouTube yeah oh my dad
vlogging [ __ ] yeah hell yeah he's still
getting a hand he's still getting the
hang of it he don't really know how he
starts off like this yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he'd be doing it too it's coming to the
iPhone for the first time I still
haven't successfully FaceTime this
[ __ ] guy he hasn't picked it up yet
um all right sorry sorry so your album's
out what is when you're making the sound
like you said well people [ __ ] with me
you gotta do the deluxe you gotta drop
some more songs two were interludes is
this like
I know you don't give a [ __ ] it's more
of a dressing like all right man shut up
yeah I'm gonna do something funny hey
say some [ __ ] I get what I get what
you're doing
for you like as a person you're going
like I always ask this there's that
moment when you're by yourself you got
done brushing your teeth you're turning
lights off you're catch the mirror like
I really did this [ __ ] where was that
one moment because I I know every
[ __ ] has it
I did I said a hard time bro especially
when I'm high wait a minute did I do
that hey what the [ __ ] going on right
now cause I just be in work more I got a
ton of vision man so I'll just be
just forget what day of the week well I
mean I did forget what month it was but
my bad I say that's the weed not tunnel
vision but so
you do it multiple all right I don't
feel stupid sometimes I feel like do I
really yeah never have like a new sack
of weed
I used to sell this [ __ ] to smoking like
oh it's just three of them so that's
when I feel like yeah I [ __ ] did okay
man get charged up yeah you get Juiced
um
okay so the sorry the music video you
said you went to space that was like a
40 [ __ ] minutes ago you really did
that's crazy you remembered that though
I'm shocked I gotta be honest you're
becoming a seasoned host yeah it used to
be called what the [ __ ] was that talking
about and it was a segment now it was a
recurring thing it came back see did you
really do zero gravity and [ __ ]
yeah man I went to space what do you
mean you went to space for real what are
you saying like you guys were I'm doing
backflips in space all that [ __ ]
and
it was amazing man are you telling you
got in a rocket ship are you saying like
you went to a studio figuratively no no
no no no no no no I actually went to
space
left Earth's plane for a second
I have two but on drugs are you [ __ ]
with me well did you guys really have a
budget to go to space yeah it was like
it was like
it's like it's called suborbital so it's
not like oh you're not kidding it's not
going space space you know what I'm
saying oh you're not kidding I thought
you were [ __ ] with me this whole time
no I written it's hard to read you yeah
that song Elon Musk supposed to be the
biggest song in the world
I did so much for that song because I
believed in it so much so I went to
space
I took over the whole astronaut field
like I really got into this [ __ ] I used
to watch I was watching YouTube videos
about space I just became like a space
geek so I went
back flips and [ __ ] and so I put it on
Tick Tock YouTube Everything well Tick
Tock I see the music video bro that is
the what the most epic [ __ ]
so here's what we're talking about from
Europe orbital like black sky space
there's still blue sky space
dark blue oh you're not [ __ ] with me
you know how you can look out you know
how you can look outside you see like
the different layers damn near darker
and darker I wasn't in space space I
shot you up dark blue with a film crew
that is the most expensive [ __ ] oh I
would oh I hope it's expensive I read
that in their notes and I'm like I
didn't take away what you just said from
I didn't realize that it was for real
like I thought like yeah we went to
their facility and they [ __ ] threw me
in his you know the Skydive thing it's
real real life yo what it was a crazy
it's the weirdest [ __ ] ever though like
because you like you can do like this
and you will fly like a dream huh yes
like if I was to like touch that like it
was sometimes I hit the wall too hard
trying because you can't swim you know
what I'm saying people think you can
swim and [ __ ] in the air you can't swim
you can do it like this you'd just be
flipping around and [ __ ] so like if you
touch something that's how you push
yourself off like imagine being in like
space space with the [ __ ] spaceship
right
and you go outside to change the engine
or some [ __ ] and you hit and you push
off that wall too hard it's over Gone
Forever they're gone you literally just
gonna die
it's crazy bro it's really crazy but
it's like you would never know that
unless you like go up there a lot and
really be experiencing that [ __ ] it's
crazy yo this is a oh bro that's the
best note that I'm so glad I brought it
up does that make you want to do more
extreme [ __ ] like right I'm a daredevil
Brad oh you are like the only thing I do
here is bunny jump every skydive
skydived
I don't know where to go I would have
been oh my my fiance did there's a
bridge that they film out here they take
like 40 people at a time if you just
smoke weed the whole time on the hike
it's like a two mile hike and you bunch
of jump off a bridge with all these
extractors you're getting less than
skydiving like I would think you would
do that first that's what I was saying
yeah but think about it bungee jumping
you ain't got nobody but the Rope
with [ __ ] skydiving you got an
instructor on your back so they jump off
with you
and then they pulled a pair of shooting
[ __ ] instead of you jump free diving and
trying to put it nah that's how you die
but but the budget job is [ __ ] is like
no I feel like it's more it's more it's
low-key more safe because you got you
got the instructor with you bungee
jumping they just throwing you off and
hoping to [ __ ] they're throwing you off
a bridge and you should just wear a
parachute just cause on the bungee right
like why not no but Diego had time to
like pull that [ __ ]
jumping at that point yeah I mean
okay I didn't think they shut out yo
you're into [ __ ] like that yeah that's
one with sharks scuba dive I've been all
through the ocean
scuba dive too
let's go free diving
oh free dive that's crazy bro
I school but I put a little tank on my
back you are a wild ass full weight
right
I swear to God bro if you go in the
ocean you gotta do this before you die
bro we're both scared to go on the ocean
hey bro [ __ ] all that you gotta learn
how to scuba dive I scuba dive every
place I go like Hawaii Maldives I went
scuba diving in Maldives
it was the most beautiful [ __ ] I ever
seen in my life the way these fish live
is like crazy
you look in the distance you see a
[ __ ] shark like two big ass sharks
like I got all this on video by the way
the news okay yeah yeah this is it's
crazy bro like they don't [ __ ] with you
like we think you would think you jump
in the water and a bunch of sharks would
just eat you and [ __ ] yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] about what you're doing they
swim around you it's crazy
I'm talking about I'm looking at
barracudas swimming past my face oh hell
did you know going into the water they
were all gonna be there yeah like it
wasn't a surprise I booked it in the
Maldives I was at this Resort
and to get to the place I had to fly
from
LA to Dubai oh [ __ ] yeah Stan Dubai for
10 hours it was a lit at it was the best
trip ever been on standby for 10 hours
like me and my girl we leave go
chill in Dubai shop around and [ __ ] then
we get back on the plane then they take
then they fly you to Mali which is like
the country of Maldives or whatever
right
then you got to take another plane
closer to another airport another Island
then you got to take a boat to the
[ __ ] um
no I did all this to get to the resort
so the resort literally like
say this is this is the resort right
this is where the rest of everybody else
at you far as [ __ ] in the middle of
nowhere so I'm in the middle of nowhere
on this Resort and you can just book
scuba diving like I do it every little
tropical place I go to I scuba dive and
you're so deprecated but it's different
every time I'm missing exit and my whole
day's all plans are done but I [ __ ]
miss my age you took planes and trips
it's because everybody I feel like
everybody go to the Maldives man that's
like that's like the top you know I'm
just looking last night at the place
look at look at the pool look at the
resort yeah it's a dummy expensive
though but yeah it's it's worth it
though it's beautiful is it the one that
has the swings in the ocean no mines had
like a a pool on the back
they give you like a [ __ ] bicycle to
ride through the um the resort because
it's all on the island
ride the bike to the resort you got a
pool in the back and then the ocean is
right there so you can just jumping in
the ocean off the back like it was lit
yeah you don't got the fear I got the
fear of the of the sugar cookies for me
and [ __ ] it scares me yeah but I promise
you they don't [ __ ] with you it's crazy
he's been preaching to me for years like
I promise you man they don't care about
you I'm a trap I swim
let me tell you I was I was swimming
with a um I went to this like shark
what's it called it's like um
Shark Tank or some [ __ ] like that they
put you in this little cage yeah and
then they throw food out
and then the sharks like swim around
yeah he did I don't know that's some
crazy [ __ ] but it was fun dude it was
cool I can't believe you're down with it
that's I never met nobody that's like I
love it I [ __ ] scoop like what
because it's like
snowboard
tried it snowboarding is so [ __ ] fun
bro I've tried it I [ __ ] with the snow I
just like going fast on the little [ __ ]
last time I had my rolling tray I was in
Denver and I slid down that [ __ ] fast
as hell bro I gotta really try you gotta
really go snowboarding bro I love that
big bears up here you've been up there
yeah I went to Big Bear and went to
Aspen damn you really do it up I went to
Aspen for some weed [ __ ] and I saw all
the skiers like uh ain't me bro you
gotta you gotta get good at it bro I'm
trying to tell you this damn you really
[ __ ] living about here this is sick
so you're using these opportunities to
go when you go to concerts like go kind
of scuba dive here yeah I may not
concerts like that's a little work but
like I mean like yeah yeah yeah sick
dude that's my [ __ ] do you film it
almost every time like all these
adventures and [ __ ] are they all videos
yeah I can show you all this [ __ ] yeah
I'll be jumping out planes all this [ __ ]
you just wear a GoPro or what are you
doing they get you a GoPro yeah and most
things when you do it they like take
pictures like an extra little package to
pay for damn you really Skydive man
that's
I mean does it really look like squares
and [ __ ] up there when you're up there
like on the uh skydiving Hawaii so
you look in this [ __ ] Island bro just
trying to hit that dot and then when you
going like you can see you can see like
the the water like getting deeper and
more shallow and [ __ ] is lit I always
feel like I have a heart attack and [ __ ]
up there from bees that's what I'm
saying that's crazy the scariest part is
going up but yeah that's what I was
gonna say on the way up thinking about
it yeah and then you line up right
and you will see a [ __ ] jump off
in front of you and you know you next
so they were like
or this is
20 times a day yeah and then they'll
jump off that [ __ ] and be gone and you
look you look out and they so [ __ ]
far real like the way how fast you fall
is crazy
so then you jump out
and it's just air
and then you like this the whole time
then you have somebody come out with a
[ __ ] camera and take pictures of you
while he flying in the middle of the air
taking pictures of you and [ __ ] then he
fly away and he put a um parachute and
[ __ ] and then like yank you up
and then you just Free Falling this is
crazy the last time I did it the uh
instructor let me steer that [ __ ] too
it was crazy bro I almost [ __ ]
everything up oh no you got two [ __ ]
highways oh no what did he take hold of
you after did you take that [ __ ] back
man it's crazy bro yo I'm trying to live
man I was saying I love the fact that
you're really out there doing a little
Target it's like you know I mean that's
Advanced dude I think you'd have to pay
me at least
300 bands of Skydive I wouldn't take
anything less than 300 bands to go out
of a plane it's you got to do it you'd
have to jump with the medic dude have to
be a medic on the back for the heart
attack a hundred oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
talking for myself man I don't know man
that are you in shock like you have to
have like at least some moments I would
imagine no matter how experienced you
are when you first hit the air and your
stomach like it's got to be horrifying
you're [ __ ] trying not to die or
you're just that much of a g where
you're just like yeah it's not this cool
today it's kind of just
let go and let God when you jump on the
plane
it's a adrenaline I like the adrenaline
I guess
nah okay no no no I
unless I'm trying to get somewhere you
don't seem like a reckless person yeah
that's what I'm saying man yeah I'm not
Reckless at all but you jump without a
plans I did not I just like I just like
the adrenaline rush of just you know
just how do you compare that to getting
on stage and seeing everybody juice the
[ __ ] up it's like the same it's kind of
the same thing yeah okay it's like a
it's like I don't know when I perform
like I get paid to perform and I perform
without even thinking about the money
like I don't do this I don't do music
for money yeah I do music for the pure
fact because I love making music
yeah and for the videos because you
could essentially stop making videos and
just do music forever right yeah yeah
you could I feel like tell me if I'm
wrong do you kind of do it just
because [ __ ] are really waiting
on the next video
I do it because I know
I inspire a lot of people and I motivate
a lot of people
and I feel like
if I just flat I'll stop that's kind of
like
a slap in the face to them thank you so
you're a real content creator yeah so I
just keep doing it but I'm I'm doing it
now where I'm trying to make it like
more so just about music revolving music
because that's what I'm really
passionate about and I know I got people
to I got to make interested in that too
still yep I heard you say like I'll put
out an r b album if I feel like it like
is that a real plan
yeah I mean I wouldn't consider myself a
singer but I did win gold on r b songs
all right and earlier I wouldn't say I'm
an athlete but I will knock your ass out
real quick silver glove yeah the most
humble [ __ ] [ __ ] ever all right hold
on I saw on your page you got the new uh
the Maybach truck
I got the no no no that was for the
video I got the Maybach car the 580.
okay how do you like it
I love it is it should drive smooth as
[ __ ]
all the features is cool it's flashy
without being too flashy like it's like
if you know you know like some people
just think it's just a Mercedes oh for
sure until you see the little yeah so
you see like the back of that [ __ ] and
you see Maybach on the pack or when you
open the door yeah yeah but I love it I
like being driven in it though I drive
it a lot so it's like it's meant to be
like
yeah it's meant to be driven you lay in
the back kick your feet up smoke
something I like I like driving myself
though because
this week I'm signing the papers
did you know the 680 is coming out soon
V12 I get to spec it my homies at
Mercedes I like I didn't tell you yet
they told me last night like I get to
sign the paperwork this week they're
bringing the V12 680 made back out
second one in existence because of the
hash house God damn it's allocations
from porch it would look like hella
different or no it's just the price
difference and it's a V12 I went
should I just get the 580 and he's like
no I'll get you under sticker and go oh
[ __ ]
so I'm juicing when I had to ask I saw
them bit like oh you got the SUV huh
because then you got a new spot and I
don't think it's gonna fit two SUVs so
I'm like I'm gonna get the sedan yeah so
when you said that like which one yeah
the 580 cool though I mean that's what I
wanted to get and he's like don't do it
what if I can help you and get this one
so he's all Juiced I don't care about
rare stuff like that but like oh no
there's only two okay that's that's kind
of tough this is about to start so it
gets uh jewelry and [ __ ] he gets on he
gets you piece of jewelry and check um
my homie does like all the uh the the
eliante uh Jeweler that's where he does
all his [ __ ] he's like you should get a
channel
I don't I don't care like I don't I'm
animated like I feel like I'll be
talking to you interview's over guys I
just broke my [ __ ] you know like it'll
Crush my soul breaking some [ __ ] I don't
think you break it though it's easily
fixed just gotta pay for it I know but
Dave it's easily again that was a six
thousand dollar mistake oh no it only
cost that much [ __ ] like for real nah
fixing jury is easy sometimes Drillers
to fix your [ __ ] for free if you just
bought some [ __ ] off of them before I
take my [ __ ] to Fast Fix like if I [ __ ]
around and is that a company Fast Fix
being every mall like you're just going
oh
[ __ ] it's like 15 and they fix the [ __ ]
out of here no [ __ ] hey fast fixes any
actually I have to do some bougie [ __ ]
say you buy like a bracelet or something
a Cuban bracelet and you want to take a
link out or something they do that [ __ ]
30 minutes you would let somebody do
that at the mall yeah they do this thing
come on bro 30 minutes
I'm gonna take all this bad I'm over
here thinking I don't want to buy this
it's so expensive
quick oh all right all right yeah cause
I just don't really [ __ ] with jewelry
because you know I never had my whole
life plus I was poor my whole life so uh
jury ain't [ __ ] man it's okay it's cool
it's just a little eye catcher and it's
for you though at the end of the day
it's like yeah [ __ ] yeah like that
that's the I think that'd be the biggest
I'd ever go right there yeah because
I've been telling it's called the Cuban
right yeah that's uh what John was
trying to tell me to get but I can't see
myself I don't see it yeah I don't see I
just like I'd rather smoke more I'd
rather have more weed I think you're
like a dude with like a 60 000 dab rig
hell no because if I break that [ __ ] you
dab no no I ain't that deep in it oh
okay okay so you just smoke do you smoke
joints or blunts joints but if somebody
got like a little backwood or you know
she's a joint smoker yeah it's [ __ ] I
smoke it if it's there you know yeah I
can't really do the backwards man so I
have to ask a DJ ghost I rolled up what
a zip of joints because I smell bad
yeah I'm so sorry because some people
are like I wouldn't smoke a bag you want
a backlight
are you particular about weed like
restrain or what type of weed you got I
just like sativa oh do you third person
in a row
that's right are you like indigers I
only smoke OG's these are all hybrids
and sativas today I'm trying I was like
my homie gave me his company I'm like
I'll try it out today they're all
smoking good so far yeah I'll say that
but yeah none of them are Indica so good
I didn't even ask myself I feel like and
it could just make you tired right yeah
I just I just uh I just get [ __ ] up
that's I mean like I smoke my job is to
get high so it's not like not really a
big thing to me do you smoke before all
the plane jump in the space flipping and
all this [ __ ] or is that not a priority
nah not if I'm trying it for the first
time because like a little scared I I
did I probably smoked before I like
scuba dive or that's kind of cool or
some [ __ ] yeah because I'm kind of like
I'm cool with that I'm more experienced
with this [ __ ]
oh man I think I just watched you
anymore how deep are you are you like
floating along the surface you going no
I'm going deep like 50 feet oh come down
there bro yeah get darker like a lamp on
I can't explain enough how beautiful
scuba diving is bro like it's crazy it's
a whole nother World down there because
you know it's only 30 percent it's 70
percent water on this Earth but it's way
more you know like what what's down
there exactly oh you're looking deep
curious yeah when you looking deep it's
like
you see little big ass [ __ ] swimming
around deep though
that's my best [ __ ] nightmare yeah
yeah you like this it's okay though some
people just like different [ __ ] I I
can't do Rosie she loves bungee jumping
she wants to go skydiving at least at
least at least snorkel at least snorkel
let me stay in the top yeah you're on
the top and you got the look you got the
life jacket on that's cool yeah yeah
only time to go go underwater is when
you jump in the water so you jump in you
come right back up with your life Jackie
you just lay on top and look I [ __ ] with
Lakes that'd be sick [ __ ] with some
Lakes Lakes it's just the monsters in
there that like you just gotta accept
like he's saying you can just accept
that easier
if a shark was to come eat me
[ __ ] that's just what it was supposed to
happen
yeah my whole time I'm getting to eat
I'm gonna go I could have been at home
as I'm punching this [ __ ] see I'm the
opposite I love that man I'm trying to I
went on the plane ride from back from
Chicago this first time and I wasn't
like losing my [ __ ] I cannot I can't I
can't fly I hate it but this last time
I'm like you know what hopefully one day
I'll be okay because [ __ ] jump
out of planes today yeah here you go
yeah so you're not afraid of plane rides
at all so you like flying to Europe and
[ __ ] yeah yeah
Benadryl pills and go to sleep what's
your favorite like fashion brands and
[ __ ] he's real into fashion too he just
kind of had to try a birthday party at
Burberry trying I'm trying stuff is
there like I need to stand out as your
favorites
like fashion brand
um I like Valencia I got a lot bro you
are rich
[ __ ] all my homies wear that [ __ ] heavy
I'm like all right I'm gonna go check it
out how much this little shirt for Rosie
I won't [ __ ] you oh yeah I'm gonna be
blowing on the shirts
the shoes I like the shoes yeah but but
him even the hood he's broke because I
mean I go to all the stores [ __ ]
rodeos and I'm like go to Balenciaga
recently and I was appalled I know it's
a expensive [ __ ] but I make the top of
the expensive [ __ ] food chain I make
clothes I looked at the shirt and go
this printing is not baked long enough I
think I think what Dior is like the most
expensive so yours
yeah but balenciag I like it because it
looked like different like they do it's
more streetwear feel yeah it's like
boozy like business yeah 100 Gucci
starting to get more into streetwear
looks like they got like more sneaker
Jordan looks right now and they're like
I've been buying the shorts like
basketball shorts lately you wouldn't
see basketball Dior shorts yeah though
ever I mean you know what I'm saying I
mean maybe I'm just
yeah
you want to hit a couple fan questions
real quick oh yeah real quick real quick
before we get out of here so uh
when we have
certain guests I will throw the picture
and go what would you ask if you could
because you're obviously a fan of people
and as a kid like yo if I was 12 again
50 Cent walked by like yo 50 Cent can I
ask you a question that's what fan
questions are in the show because you
don't always get the opportunity I don't
understand I maybe say inside joke we
had like 200 people say ask him about
his real voice I'm like what does that
mean is that an inside joke nah it's
real
what they think your voice isn't real
um I I really don't what the [ __ ] out of
here that's not how you're really
talking that is my real voice I just
talk like this when I'm trying to like
make music and make content and [ __ ]
but I really talk like this in real life
[ __ ] out of here you can ask anybody
that's how I really talk you talk like
my fat like when I'm around my family
and [ __ ] that's I do that but then you
know you got to make a character so
yeah it is like my
damn that fits your face better though
like yeah like that seems like it would
be your tone damn I can't do that I
can't read you at all bro I usually I
got people within the first couple
minutes but yeah
I know that's what everybody said
see I'm dead ass serious okay everybody
say that [ __ ] I'll just be like man real
quick
it's been a thing for a minute
you might be the greatest actor of all
time oh yeah
this whole time he's gonna come and take
his hair off like by the way guys
laughs
yeah I'm glad that I'm so [ __ ] happy
that you asked that question because
that was I didn't expect that at all you
could do a whole album in your actual
voice yeah once you do a Barry White
Album
I feel like this is more fit type [ __ ]
you ever seen the movie Fern Gully you
sound like Tone Loc
yeah what Barry White had a whole career
off that voice you gotta feature
yourself on a song
Some Nutty Professor [ __ ] like wear a
different suit different bodysuit and
played do you get paid twice and then
produce it for yourself and just get
paid
all right I think okay it's not me it's
you yeah not your album I was going
through it with Marty and I went you
know there's a lot of big [ __ ]
features on this [ __ ] so you must be
juicy [ __ ] yeah and that's what we
talked about earlier and that was about
40 minutes ago so what happens
Polo G right mle Chop on there I see
what was it Kevin Gates Kevin Gates is a
wild [ __ ] he's another fool that
was just popular as hell off of
something that wasn't music remember I
mean it was music too but do you
remember when Kevin Gates came out he
was just the guy on interviews like
shocking the [ __ ] out of people with
yeah the [ __ ] he was saying then he
started dropping music and he was like
so yeah you got a career on your hands
you know what I mean so I saw Kevin
Gates and I'm like man this Fool's
really coming up Kevin Gates is on
featuring on people's albums and [ __ ]
like this Kevin Gates Southern on Arenas
they see like I was about to say the
next thing I listened to underground
[ __ ] a lot and then old stuff so when I
see new music I just hit because we're
we're Spotify like we're partners and
[ __ ] so I'll go on like top ten so when
I clicked on there and I'm like damn you
know you're crushing it you're doing a
good job on a whole nother thing that's
not even YouTube so my first question
was do you feel like you need to there's
a connect or you feel a little like ah
am I gonna be all right with this
YouTuber leaving this thing behind but
you still have to be there for your fans
that got you to where you are and that's
why you're like no people might motivate
people so it's not me it's you you put
this album out just came out
and how are you like I mean it's the
hardest question ever but it kind of
reverts back to that you're by yourself
you turn the light off like hey good job
[ __ ] so you're having these
artists that like you said you probably
listened to already you're having them
all on your album
how are you uh
receiving this man have you seen
yourself on the billboard yet have you
watched yeah I went to New York to see
myself in a big billboard it was dope
it was like crazy everybody that
listened to us said they love it so you
know that's the real goal is there
anybody you really want to work with
that you haven't yet
um
yeah it's a lot of artists actually
be a top person
say Drake
cardi BB fire
[Music]
um
you know what I'm like yeah the big ones
I could say like the career landmarks
yeah I'm still astonished by that voice
change yeah bro I've never stopped
thinking about that [ __ ] I still don't
know if you smoke with me so we'll leave
it with that but um so yeah this album's
this album's out everything's going good
for you man
um how you feeling about the deluxe
edition
yeah so if you listen to the original
it's just
you know it's more chill it's more like
talking about love and getting
heartbroken and you know relatable [ __ ]
that everyone gets a lot of stuff yeah
yeah
and then the deluxe is more like turn up
you know second part of your life yeah
yeah like the second stage yeah yeah
it's just turning up and just who speaks
who's featured on the second Deluxe part
um I got a song with coiler and lakia
and then I got a song officer set that's
right and then you said coil array she
was on the first one too or did okay no
no no she was on my last project oh
because Spotify just started looping
let's Spotify does a good job of making
sure you're like oh no you like this oh
here's a [ __ ] shitload of it so
they're good at it man they're good at
so how can everybody find your album how
can we listen to this apple Spotify for
music Spotify
uh platforms YouTube YouTube yeah so I
went through your uh YouTube scrolled
so much music back to back man I
scrolled all the way and then I realized
yeah you did it right you're supposed to
separate your [ __ ] yeah you let yourself
funnel back in so yeah you're doing the
I guess you could see like a blueprint
of oh yeah you cannot you can also be
the YouTuber but also because there's so
many there's this is the first time in
history that you can make a career of
yourself off of the internet yeah I'm
sure you started with just your phone
you made an account then you're like oh
look at my AdSense I'll start this [ __ ]
up I'm like oh I made money [ __ ]
so that's how this all started so I'd
like to see
like somebody else's perspective that's
done kind of the same thing we're doing
like wow it's getting a little bigger
than YouTube this is this is cool so I
like to see the stage and you're at the
stage of Blast Off well the Elon Musk is
kind of the whole point of I'm about to
get big and blow up I get it it's sick
um so the deluxe edition by for everyone
is going to be out by the time this is
out but uh DTG on all platforms like
everyone can find you on social media
that way yeah everything man is there
anything different they got to do for
the deluxe like is it yeah it's on there
you just separate as of yeah so it's a
separate thing from the original going
download it separately yeah download it
listen to it to me if you like it
question for me last one
when your album comes out do you like
get a CD made or like a something I
don't know yeah vinyl do you do you do
any of that [ __ ] no no no no I don't
have a record player so it's like I get
it just to frame that be a sick gift uh
yeah homies homies out here it's a sick
gift I don't know it's just something
because you know you remember going to
like would you have Sam goody and what
would you have as a kid
what did you buy CDs at as a little ass
kid
Target oh yeah that's right Walmart
honestly I'm go to your Warehouse that
warehouse place so you remember like
getting that cover art looking in the
back staring like damn the tracklist
like [ __ ] they take the CD off and those
little things in the middle break all
the [ __ ] time I don't know I just
feel like even if you dropped 100 like
those the hardcore fans are gonna frame
that [ __ ] when the next pop-up you do
like hey sign this like it's different
when someone's like yo you traveled to
get here juice the whole time yeah I
wish I like got the experience that
their era of music as a as an artist and
not a listener you know what I mean yeah
but at least you had a little bit of it
because you're like do you you know what
I'm saying so I was just saying if you
if you made one for yourself because I
think I would have to hit something
tangible to hold my music I think so yes
sir yeah but no dude thank you so much
for being here I know we're just sitting
here smoking and talking [ __ ] four more
interviews today are you really yeah I
do actually I guess spots already I'm
sorry well you take these joints I got
another one over here for you okay all
right thanks so much for being here man
this is uh this is cool I know the fans
are super stoked
cool to see a YouTuber transition and
actually do some dope [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
excited for you man so good thing good
[ __ ] Marty anything else thank you sir
this was awesome I love seeing somebody
out of uh I'm from Buffalo so I kind of
like the same area we just had Chevy
Woods on here out of Pittsburgh so it's
like people really kind of blowing that
area up whole Great Lakes area these
small little cities that haven't really
had success on YouTube
want to do music why not want to do
whatever why not just keep heart laying
exactly guys
um you guys remember go get the music
it's not me it's you just dropped this
past couple weeks not a month all right
you just dropped guys thank you so much
this is the ddg episode thank you so
much for being here bro for sure man
this has been the dope podcast guys have
a dope ass day
pretty [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign